um so I want to show a photo that you
posted because this is me
um
this is all of us
um this is rare though for a mom I feel
like to get a minute without your yeah I
literally the last bath this is no joke
the last bath I took my kids got in the
bathroom still and I locked it I thought
still got in and I literally this is no
joke I taped something and sent it to my
band not me in the bath I just made like
that would have been an appropriate HR
um but um no I I taped it and I was like
they won't leave me alone and I was just
filming my kids and not leaving me alone
in the bath how did you get alone time
sure this one this is really rare for me
too the balancing act as a mom I mean it
is honest to God the hardest thing we
all know this yeah but I I have to like
set a time and if I don't set a time to
do it I don't do it yeah so it's like
I'm scheduling you know at 8pm this is
happening I don't know what meltdown's
going on I don't know what's going on
but I'm doing it yeah and so obviously
if a glass of wine isn't involved even
better we're just relaxing the Beth is
so good we do so much all the time and I
don't I I talk about it a lot but if I
don't actually schedule it I don't do
time for myself like or force it because
like sometimes because even the last
bath I took I was like or I could just
lay in bed yes and then and now it's
like your body needs it like the Epson I
got like lavender I get into a bath girl
I have like a whole setup yeah I'm like
rose oil I'm like same mandals and
they're like put a cup of Epsom salt I'm
like dump the whole bath
a cop
it depends on the size of your bathtub I
guess you know the chemistry of it but I
put a lot like half the back the same I
was like we need to cleanse like we're
putting half the lavender I've like
doped myself into a soup super like I'm
just totally tired really great because
I put the whole bag in my back so I do
the same I love that for you every mom
was like yes and Dad maybe like baths
too I don't know yeah
[Music]
[Applause]